el tercer día de protestas en Perú
bloquean 59 puntos de tránsito hay 14
vías nacionales afectadas en 10 regiones
de este país el desborde social se
registra principalmente en el sur del
Perú en las localidades de puno cusco
tacna sicuani y abancay donde los
manifestantes amenazan a los dueños de
negocios para que no abran sus comercios
y se unan a la jornada de lucha en Lima
la situación está en aparente calma pero
las protestas del interior impactan en
el abastecimiento de alimentos en el
gran mercado mayorista de Lima ha dejado
de recibir alrededor de 20% de productos
Mientras tanto comuneros aymaras
preparan la movilización de 30.000
indígenas para intentar tomar las
ciudades de puno y Lima con la finalidad
de rechazar al gobierno de la presidenta
Dina boluarte los comuneros creen que La
amenaza de cerrar la capital peruana
impulsaría sus exigencias de renuncia de
la mandataria el cierre del parlamento y
la convocatoria elecciones generales y
en medio de esto la dispuso investigar a
la presidenta Dina boluarte al Primer
Ministro Alberto botárola y a los
ministros de defensa y el interior por
las muertes ocurridas durante las
manifestaciones realizadas en diciembre
de 2022 al respecto la presidenta
boluarte aceptó el inicio de las
indagaciones el Ministerio Público la
mandataria sostiene que es fundamental
que se sancione penalmente a quienes
ocasionaron 28 muertes y más de 300
heridos